はい それから最後のセクションに入ります
仏典に出てくる悪魔 お釈迦様がよく悪魔について語られます
ものすごいこのマーラということ
マーラの領域 まああれこれと魔王とかね
いっぱい単語を使って語っています
決してまああの この一神教
一神教で言っているような
もうとんでもない敵のせいでという変な考え方じゃないんです
ほとんど文学的な表現で
あるいはまあ語りやすいということもあります
六つの感覚器官と属 属
コンテンツ 六つの感覚器官から情報が触れるということ
ルーパサッダーガンダンラサーガンダパッサダンマーチェケーラエタンローカスミンゴーランエッタローコウイムッチと
色相にこう触れるもの
その他の現象 いわゆる法ですね
これらはこれらはこの世で生命において恐ろしいものである
世はこれらに夢中になっている
世っていうのは生命のこと
これ見えるもの 聞こえるものあるでしょうと
これってえらい怖いんだよ
だって見えるものねって心の中で欲が生まれたり
怒りが生まれたり 煩悩が生まれるんだから
怖いんだ 何か聞くと心はどんな変化を起こすかと
知った問題ないんですよ
大変です しかし 私たちはそれを知らないで
見えるものに 聞こえるものに夢中
美しいものを見たい 美しい音を聞きたいと
美味しいものを食べたい
美味しいものに触れたいと夢中なんです
エータンチェサマティッカマサトブッダッササーワコマーラデイヤンアティッカマーディッチョービョーチェティ
これら六感に触れる方に執着することですね
を 気づきが ある必要 ある仏弟子は乗り越える
ちょっとある入れときます
この眼耳鼻舌身に情報が触れますよ
怖いんです これで心が汚れるんだから
これでもの大変なことになるんで
自分の体の中 なんか放射能があるところにいるような感じなんです
放射能が入って入って体を壊すんだから
で いつでも見えるもの
聞こえるものという放射がもう体にずっと触れてるんです
で 心が汚れてるんです
怖いこと しかし 仏弟子たちは
執着しない ものを見えても執着しない
気づきを持って執着しないことにする
ことを聞く 聞いても執着しないことにする
乗り越えるんですね 悪魔の領域を破り
太陽のごとく輝く と こっちは悪魔が出たんですね
この領域っていうのは
この国なん禁断ですよ
悪魔の王国に我々は住んでいるんです
だからこれ 国を破って出ていくってことは大変難しいんです
国の国民だからね 魔国の
魔国 魔国の国民だから
国籍を変えなくちゃいかんだからね
しかし 仏弟子たちはちゃんとこの六識
なんで魔国にしてますかというと
六識に我々囲まれているんだからね
眼耳鼻舌身の情報に囲まれているんだからね
これ破りますよ 破って太陽のごとく輝きますよ
正直と勝負 イェージャコーサンマダッカーテダンメダンマノワッティノテーラナーパラメッサンティマッチュデーヤンスドゥッタラ
また悪魔が出るんです
正しく語られた これは知ります
真理 正しく語られた真理を知り
それに従うならば その人々は天命を乗り越える
悪魔の領域は越えがたいものである
これ歌ですよ 大体今までずっと喋ったことをすごくまとめて縮めてありますね
この毒色の毒 毒式の問題と
そこから出てくる愚痴の問題
存在輪廻が悪魔 存在そのもの
輪廻そのものが苦しみの限りのない回転です
人間が徹底的に悪いものに
悪いもの良いことは微塵もないものに悪魔と名付けるので
だから世の中は悪いものに悪魔と言うんです
良いことっていうのは
微塵もないことない人にサタンやらルシファーやらなんとか言うんです
悪魔とかね お釈迦様が輪廻そのものを悪魔だと単語の定義変えたんです
神に逆らったルシファーという天使がもう完全に真っ黒い悪魔なんです
微塵もないんだそうです
いいことところ という風に世の中で言ってるんだから
お釈迦様が完全に悪い輪廻そのものに悪魔っていう名前をつけたんです
悪魔は輪廻だよ だからお釈迦様が借りたのは神話ではないんです
単語とその意味だけ それで悪魔っていうのはいろいろいるんです
1 これから仏教の話 カンダマーラ
体を構成している五蘊に人は執着する
したがって五蘊がマーラです
いわゆる私は悪魔ですという意味なんです
体が構成しているのは肉体と感覚と概念と
それから心っていうですね
1つ色受想行識と衝動がありますね
それで 5つ 我々はそちらにすごい執着しているんです
それで輪廻転生になります
だから この体そのものが
体って言ったってこの心も入ってます
悪魔です それはカンダマーラというんです
2番目 キレーサマーラ
煩悩 感情に誘惑されて苦の世界を彷徨っているから感情がマーラです
それから感情に奴隷化されているでしょうに
感情で考える 感情で生きている
ですから 感情そのもの
煩悩そのものにも悪魔と呼ぶんです
3番目サンカーラマーラ
因縁によって現れる無常不苦無我である
一切の現象はマーラです
一切の現象 心も体も物質も宇宙も何でもかんでも
全部無常です 無害です
空です ろくなものじゃないんです
だからすべてのサンカーラが現象はマーラと言うんです
これ 3番目の悪魔です
4番目 マッチュマーラ
生まれたものは必ず死ぬ
これこそ避けたいという努力は生きること
必ず死ぬんだけど 避けたいんです
この避けようすることに生きているということをするんです
しかし 確実に死ぬ 命は死によって抑えられているから
死はマーラです この場合
ちょっと言葉が似ていますよ
マーラとマーラといえば
死にパーリ語で使います
世界でも同じことですけど
だから我々は誰かに首きというか
首に鎖つけて足に鎖つけて繋いでいるように
誰かに掴まれているんです
誰かというと死 逃げられません
死が我々の両手 両足 首
もう何でも もう鎖で破れない鎖で繋いで繋げています
だから人 生命の死も悪魔マーラというんです
で  5番目デーヴァダッタマーラ
天界に仏道修行を好まない
修行の邪魔をする神々がいる
その一部の神々にもマーラというんです
邪魔やという感じでね
これってそんな不思議なことじゃなくて
まあ大体まあみんな同じ意見じゃないんだから
まあ嫌や この修行する連中はっていう神々が天界にいるんですね
だから何か邪魔をするんです
それは一般人には邪魔しません
だから気にする必要はない
もう本当に悟るために
解脱するために この五智を変えるために修行する人々にあえて邪魔をするんです
ヘリの宗教を修行する場合は関係ないんです
どうせ悪魔の世界だからね
だからちょこちょこ瞑想していただかれて
悪魔は悪魔の神々が来るわけじゃないんです
本気になっても愚痴を破ろうとしていると
ちょっと何かいたずらしたり
何かやったりはする どうもイライラするみたいです
しかし 大体はもうそこはそんなにどうったことはない
もう簡単にもう向こうはこし上げます
そういうことで  5種類のマーラがいるんです
次に悪魔の軍 軍隊 軍隊の悪魔がいるんです
この場合は軍隊っていうのはあるかな
悪魔の環境で自分も悪魔として生きているから
善行為をすることさえも難しい
環境が悪魔でしょ 私が
私が悪魔と言ったってもね
私だけっていうことじゃないでしょ
それから人間でなくても
自然環境も自分たち悪魔でしょ
花を見て喜びを感じるわ
だからそうどうしようもないんですよ
だから悪魔の環境の中で悪魔で生きているんです
だから ちょこっとしたつまらない良いことでもするのは大変難しい
ちょっとした良いことをすることもものすごい難しい
だからよく言う  1日１善でもしてくださいと
とんでもない話ですよ
1日１善というということは
1日中悪いことになってもいいということなんです
1個だけいいことをして
他何やってもいいという
だから私の分析ではそうなりますけど
これは禅の言葉ですけど
よく考えてみるとね もう最低 1日 1個だけでもしなさいということでしょう
それもやらないでしょう
1日1善 私から見れば何やこれということ
1日1善ですか ということは
ずっと悪いでいいんじゃないのかという話ですけど
それでも人間は 1日 1個の善行為もしないんです
しないのは何でしょうかね
やっぱり難しいんですよ
そんな気にならない 我々は自分悪魔だから
これできません だから
修行はなおさら難しい
もう修行のことはもうものすごい難しい
勇者の忍耐 努力が必要になるのです
だから修行するというと
かなり勇気を振り絞らないと
かなり覚悟をしないといけないんです
自分が自分自身と戦わなくてはならないんです
自分が悪魔だから すごい難しい
自分で自分と戦って 自分
悪魔を倒さなくちゃいけない
それも自分なんです だから悪魔との戦いっていうのは
自分が自分との戦いなんです
そういうわけで 仏教もこの他宗教でどちらでも育っている一般的な言葉を使います
悪魔と戦いましょうと
しかし 宗教でいうような人間の闘争本能を応援しているわけではないのです
そこで戦争をイメージして語るのです
もう戦いです 戦争をイメージして語るのです
悪魔の軍隊 釈尊が修行中
悪魔の軍隊と一人で戦って勝ち抜いて正覚者になったのです
苦行中は三回も死にかけたのです
生きていた いわゆる何にも達しないで死ぬよりは生きていた方が良いのではないかと心の揺らぎもありました
お釈迦様の努力っていうのは
誰にもできないということになってますから
苦行とかね 悟るために苦行はいりませんだけど
知らないんだからやってみたんです
だから初めはお釈迦様の愚痴なんですよ
愚痴で悟りたい だから苦行やってやるそうで
結果がなかったんです
六年ほどんと苦行なんです
だから死にかけるんですよ
それで苦行は結果ないということでやめて
普通の瞑想で悟りましたけど
だから心は結構揺らぐでしょう
このこの調子ならもう明日も体持たないんだと
まだ悟るという見込みもないんだと
というか ただ単に死ぬだけでしょうと
生きたった方がいいんじゃないかなとか
心の揺らぎはあったでしょうね
勝たなくてはならない十種類の軍隊を制する
それで自分を なんていいますか
奮い立たせるために 勇気を出すために
お釈迦様も王家の人でしょ
王子でしょ だから戦争の技術というかね
まあ武術はもうプロなんです
だからお釈迦様にとっては古の頃から学んだ世界で
武術っていうのは だからこれは戦いだと
自分との で しっかりと軍隊は誰なのか
敵軍は誰なのかとはっきりとしたんです
よし わかったと これぐらい軍隊十軍なんです
十字軍じゃないんです
そこを紹介します カーマテパテマーセナドゥティアーアレティウッチャティ
タティヤコッピパーサーテチャトゥッティチャトゥッティタンナーパウッチャティ
汝の第一群は愛欲です
興味が失うことは第二群です
私は今日 1 日中これでやられていたんです
お腹がすく 喉が渇くってコッピパーサ
第三群です 活は生き続けたいということ
渇愛が第四群です しっかりと敵軍をしっかりと区別しております
だから頑張る人にとっては邪魔になるものでしょ
お腹がすいた 例えば森で修行するとする
お腹がすくたびに食べるものはないでしょうに
もし 2時半ぐらいでお腹がすいたならば
またすっごくお腹がすいたまま朝次の日までいなくちゃダメ
托鉢に行くために 嫌だ
やめたと減速するそうと思っちゃえば終わりなんです
そういうわけで そういう人間修行すると出てくるいろんな障害を群体にして分けてるんです
これで四群まで説明しました
パンチャマンティーナミッタンジェチャッタービールパウッチャティ
サッタミーリチキッチャーテマッコータンボーッティアッテーモ
でお前という風に 汝という風に言ってるんです
汝のという感じで だから昏沈睡眠は第五群です
汝の 恐怖感 怯えが第六群です
第七群は疑いです 他人を見下す気持ち
強情 頑固は第八群です
これよく勉強になりますよ
だから我々でも何かやると
この十群でやられますよ
疑いでもあんまりもうはっきりしない
優柔不断で何もできんでしょうに
あるいは昏沈睡眠で眠く眠くてだるくてやりたくないなとかね
寝たいなとか それで何もできなくなるんですよ
修行するとなおさら攻撃
攻撃するんですよ 眠気が攻撃するわ
お腹がすいた 喉が渇いたどうかなるわ
だからそれをはっきりした方がいいってことです
ラーホーシローコーサッカーローミッチャーランドジャヨーナスヤスオーヨーチャッターナンサモッカンセーパレーチャールジャーナティ
利益って収入のこと 供養
人々からいろんなものをもらうことなんです
それが八群ですね  8番目
ごまかしで得る名誉 大体みんななんとか工夫して
なんか褒めてもらいたくて
人気を得たくて頑張っているんです
これも一つの悪魔なんです
自分を持ち上げて他を軽視する行為
これは 10番目の群体です
これが汝のと言ったっても
他人のじゃないんです
自分なんです この悪魔は
自分の心にその十群がいるんです
それでなんで悪魔という第三人称で語るかというか
この第一人称 二人称で語るのかという
汝の やっぱり周りも同じ十群で我々を誘惑するんです
寝ようよ もうまあこの時間だからとかね
修行すると何か食べようとかね
それで自分も同じでだからすぐこう繋げてしまいます
そういうわけで 悪魔という言葉を使った方が便利なんです
なんとなく外から攻撃されているような気分もあるし
中身から自分ではないかという気分もあるんです
だからこの両方考えてるんです
私たちは自分が悪魔だから
十群は自分持っている
しかし 周りから影響を受けるんだから
周りにもその十群がいるんです
そういうわけで 悪魔にしてしまってるんです
それは一つの表現の仕方なんです
エーサーナムチテーセーナーカンナカンナッサーヴィッパパハリニー
ナナンアスーロジナティジェッダーチャラバッテースッカホロホロ
すごい難しいパーリ語ですごい古い
ナムチよ 悪しき者に仕える軍はこれです
決して勇者ではないと勝てないのです
しかし 勝利を得られたら幸福になるのです
このナムチヨっていうのはもうナンジョと同じ悪魔の名前なんです
本当はナムチっていうのは神の名前なんです
あの邪魔をする まあこの場合
まあいいやってその名前を入れてるんです
別に この神様に名乗ったら怒られるかもしれませんけど
もっと邪魔してやるぞと言ったって
そちらも同じことやってますから
そちらに文句言えません
それからもう最後 これはもうちょっと余分に時間の余ったら説明しようかなと
余ってないんですけど
時間 どうしますかね ちょっとしかないんです
あの悪魔との対話というね
経典の一つ 言わない文句で出してもありますね
中村元先生とかね 確かにあります
あれって何なのかと 相手役として悪魔はよく登場します
仏教で その時 悪魔の役は世間の一般論
常識的に正しいと認めていることが事柄を釈尊に異論として出すことです
だから仏教にも悪魔がないと成り立たないんです
結局は それで悪魔の役目は
世間の人々の考え方を異論として仏教に出して攻撃する
それで仏教は答え出しています
例えば 財産があること
子孫がいることこそが幸福である
これは世間論でしょ 財産がいっぱいあれば
まあいい子供がいればなんて幸せでしょう
世間と それから命を粗末にしてはならない
喜ばせるべきで せっかく生きているんだから
楽しんで喜んで生きてみなさいよというのは世間論なんです
そういうのをブッダに出すんです
悪魔が お釈迦様はすごく説法するのです
世間の見解と真の幸福に達する真理の世界は正反対であることを示すところです
だから悪魔でなきゃダメなんですよ
目連尊者が来たり サーリプッタ尊者や仲間が来て
あんたこう言ったってもこうではない
それ言えないでしょうに
最低アーナンダ比丘がこじでもこうする
王にもお釈迦様が言うことはちょっとおかしいんだよ
言えないんですよ だから悪魔を登場させるのです
だから遠慮なく仏教に攻撃できるんです
仏教は世間に対して皆様に法を教えているから
当然法は悪魔との対話になるんです
だってみんな悪魔でしょうに
だから仏教はやっぱり悪魔との対話で成り立っています
だから日本で私の話を聞いたっても
いろんなこと 皆様のことをあれだ
なんでこんなことするの？なんでこうなるのかとかね
なんか皆様の日常茶飯事
生き方をが攻撃されていますよね
働くなよとかね なんでこんなに怠け者でしょうかとかね
だから仏教を語る場合は
これはいつでも悪魔との対話になるんです
真理知らないんだから
皆様にしたっても 世間の常識というところにいるんです
これで説法でも聞いてやろうかなと思ったら
くたくた攻撃されるんです
一つも賛成してくれない
ああ よかった あなたも同じ意見だとか一度も言われませんよ
これからは ただ 前の質問があったように
こういう風に理解すればよろしいでしょうかと聞かれたら
正しければその通りでよろしいと言うんだけど
ああ よかった 同じ意見でということになりません
かなりやられます 不幸
はい それで終わりと思います
不幸の落とし穴を 自分が掘っています
地獄の蓋を自分で開けてるんですよ
自業自得 自得とは正しい法則です
良いことにせよ 悪いことにせよ
地獄が自業自得なんです
自分以外に真犯人を探さないこと
それが結論です 終わりです
ありがとうございます